[Music]
who would have thought that one Disney
photo could break the Internet the new
wreck-it Ralph to sleepover photo has
everyone screaming the having noticed
some of the details
the internet is liveth that these
princesses are missing don't forget to
hit that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out the missing Disney
Princesses understand her she's from the
other studio Jasmine couldn't make it
can we first talk about the fact that
everyone seemed to notice one crucial
Disney princess couldn't make it to the
sleepover we're pretty heartbroken that
Jasmine didn't make the cut on this
photo it's strange because she was
definitely there in the first trailer if
you paid attention you could see her
right next to Cinderella who was ready
to shank Penelope with her glass slipper
you could even see her when Penelope
first appears in the princess room so
how come she wasn't included in the
sleepover twitter is an impressed that
we haven't seen more of her though
people are pointing out that it is
possible there's more to this picture
the room the princesses are in pretty
much looks like the same as the last
room so there's a good chance jasmine is
still there or at least we hope she is
because we just love to see her sleep
over outfits who knows maybe she'll get
a new trailer that will give us some
more details on what to expect in this
crazy movie what do you think Jasmine
would be wearing in a sleepover we're
thinking a light blue robe and she'd
most likely be chilling on her carpet
question is would Jasmine share the
carpet with any other Disney Princess
what would that even look like seriously
Disney has to show with the steam
because it would be fantastic just
imagine Jasmine breaking down her story
to another princess epic seriously epic
speaking of sleepover these princesses
can seriously rock just about any outfit
there is even casual sleepwear don't
they look amazing
Mulan's totally casual look is probably
the best of them all but back to missing
Disney Princesses because we're still
not okay with these that weren't in the
photo we'll take a look at more details
about the sleepover photo as we talk
about the missing Disney Princesses so
make sure you stay tuned until the end
where's Belle we're pretty sure there's
no way Disney would actually forget
about Belle but she is missing from the
slumber party
she was definitely present in the first
trailer you could clearly spot her in
her gorgeous yellow dress maybe Belle
was just reading a book somewhere off
screen
she must be included in the sleepover
right she would be a perfect character
for it unless of course she's busy
taking care of whatever is happening in
the land of descendants which is a whole
nother story to be fair it would
probably make more sense if the missing
Disney Princesses just went out to get
some more food but you honestly never
know with Disney
there could be a different storyline
going on for these characters Val's
absence was definitely noted by several
Twitter users and many were speculating
what sleepwear would she wear we have a
feeling Belle would definitely Rock some
reading glasses and gigantic B slippers
as her chosen slumber party outfits
speaking about this before we move on to
other missing princesses let's have a
look at their awesome sleepwear Disney
did an amazing job with these outfits if
you pay enough attention you'll actually
notice that most Disney Princesses wear
something totally relatable to their
movie for example else's shirt says just
let it go and we all know what that
means
sorry if that song got stuck in your
head now even Cinderella has an amazing
detail on her outfit hers is a pumpkin
shaped carriage with a g2g stain that of
course stands for got to go we told you
this is turning out to be pretty meta
and we're totally here for it Mulan has
moo shu on her outfit which is
absolutely adorable we also love that
she's the only one that's not actually
in typical few days after all move on
always did things her way and we just
love that she's clearly just as
headstrong and wreckit-ralph too but
let's go back to another missing
princess the internet can't seem to find
on the slumber party photo did aurora go
to the bathroom Aurora really can't
catch a break can she she only appeared
in the trailer for a couple of seconds
sure it was enough to have a clear
vision of her but we'd love to see more
of this underrated princess you have to
admit we don't spend enough time talking
about Aurora and she definitely deserves
her time to shine hopefully we'll get to
see that in the movie but by the looks
of it the slumber party doesn't feature
her either did she have to
the bathroom or maybe the missing
princess had another job to do after all
all the coolest ones are missing
including our last one who knows maybe
Disney sent them on a secret mission or
perhaps they were just getting more food
at that moment since we could see Aurora
in the newest trailer speaking of food
on his shirt is definitely hilarious
it's a direct reference to frozen and a
quote from one of the cutest songs ever
she's wearing a shirt with a sandwich
with a text that reads let's finish each
other's of course the correct version
would be let's finish each other's
sentences but the frozen version makes
it much better with sandwiches
we're totally here for it but there's
one more princess that's missing from
the picture and the internet is livid
about it seriously where's Merida there
were some pretty serious debates over
Meredith absence in the first trailer
and the slumber party but if you paid
attention you know that she actually was
present sure it was just for a couple of
seconds and she was clearly overshadowed
by other princesses but she was there
you'd think Disney would listen and
actually add her in the slumber party to
show more of her but nope she's not
there seriously where is she as a
princess with a unique personality and
an even better storyline Merida
definitely deserves her time to shine we
just hope she'll get to do it in the
actual movie we'd hate to be
disappointed if we see that our fave
wasn't actually there but people really
noticed Merida isn't really included in
wreck-it Ralph two people on Twitter
pointed out that while many Disney
Princess fans can be excited about this
movie Merida fans just won't share the
same excitement well at least if we're
judging from the trailer and the
sleepover photo who knows what will
happen in the actual movie one person
even pointed out that it makes sense
Merida is embarrassed since she's not
like the other princesses let's be
honest she probably doesn't like Girl
Talk all that much but hey roulade is
there and we all know her in Merida
would get along much better than any
other princess at the party but if you
saw the newest wreck-it Ralph - trailer
you know it's all good because Merida
delivers one of the most hilarious
scenes ever
give mommy a key she turned into a big
beer Mojang try to deer then is no pure
mass I don't know where other details
sprung the slumber party we've already
pointed out some of the fashion choices
of the Disney Princesses in the photo
but let's have a look at some other
details people are pointing out that
tiana looks totally different in the
slumber party than she does in the
trailer sure her natural hair might look
slightly different but that's not the
only difference people have pointed out
that her eyebrows look different and
they even seemed to have narrowed her
nose the difference is quite noticeable
isn't it and we all know Disney had to
adjust focus look to fit the modern-day
style but she does look pretty different
in the sleepover photo her face also
looks much sharper speaking of
difference Snow White also had a
makeover since the trailer it could be
just the distance but her eyes looked
smaller and differently shaped we're
loving the Apple detail on her PJ's
she's really embracing what has happened
to her isn't she and did you notice
Tiana's Starbucks drink and the fact
that honest seems to really want it just
look at how she's staring at it Tiana
did open a restaurant but who knows
maybe a modern-day Tiana would actually
open Starbucks she could probably use as
much coffee as she could get and Ariel
is totally not into whatever's going on
come to think of it what is she rolling
her eyes at could she be glancing at
another Disney Princess off screen and
did you notice how her pencil and Moana
are in this strange position that makes
it seem Rapunzel's legs are chillin on
Mona's we're not sure what's happening
there but it's definitely adorable and
of course we can't ignore how cool bulan
looks as she's just max and relaxing in
the sofa her shoes look absolutely
awesome out of all Disney Princesses is
perhaps the most shocking seen
Cinderella we're totally ordinary
clothes like PJs she looks like a
completely different person doesn't she
there's just so much to love about this
movie and we absolutely can't wait to
see how these storylines are going to
develop and what will happen so win is
wreck-it ralph - coming out you won't
have to wait much longer to see wreck-it
Ralph - in cinemas the official release
date of the movie is the 21st of
November 2018 will definitely be the
first one in line the best part about
the movie is that almost
all original Disney Princesses will come
to reprise their roles which means
you'll be hearing Kristen Bell as Anna
Mandy Moore as Rapunzel
idina menzel as Elsa and so on and on we
can't wait to get all the
behind-the-scenes moments of this movie
because we all know they're going to be
totally iconic but it's not just Disney
characters that will be joining this
movie the latest news report that the
one and only gal gadot asked aka Wonder
Woman is joining the cast but of course
she won't be playing Wonder Woman she's
actually playing shank a tough racing
driver from an online game called
slaughter race seriously this cast list
keeps getting better and better it
really is clear that wreck-it Ralph - is
actually going to break the internet and
we can't wait to see it happen will we
see more of the missing princesses
here's some good news for all you Merida
and Belle fans it's not over yet and
you'll still be able to enjoy the movie
because your faves will be in it all
Disney princesses that weren't in the
sleepover are actually present in the
official movie well at least according
to the movie credits and the small
cameos in the trailer Belle is played by
page O'Hara Jasmine's voice belongs to
Linda Larkin and Meredith's played by
Kelly Macdonald as of August 2018
Belle's voice is only rumored to be
portrayed by Kate Higgins and nothing
seems to be confirmed yet on the final
decision but we're pretty sure we'll get
to see more of Belle - who knows maybe
Disney will also include the unofficial
princesses like mogera who definitely
deserves her spot on the list
since both Elsa and Anna get to be in
the movie perhaps Disney should also
look at mogera Elena Sofia the first and
several other princesses that deserve
their time to shine we definitely love
to see them interact with some of the
other iconic princesses but truth be
told we first have to make sure Merida
will get her spotlight in this movie
make sure to give this video a thumbs up
if you want Merida to be shown more and
the rest of the story we'll just have to
wait and see what wreckit-ralph to
brings we're pretty sure the movie will
release a few more teasers before we get
to see the final version of the movie in
the cinema but so far we have to say
that the sleepover definitely has us
very intrigued the princesses are so
adorable around Savannah
P of course that could also be because
their modern-day versions also have
several kids at least according to
descendants imagine the craziness if
wreckit-ralph to decides to combine the
storyline with descendants characters
now that's a fanfiction we'd love to
read make sure to come let us know which
princess you are most excited of seen in
wreck-it Ralph - we can't even choose
our faves we just can't wait to see all
of them interact with one another it's
truly a magical moment for any Disney
fan and that's it for our video thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]